There may come a point in one's relationship where you hit a bump in the road.
To maintain a strong chemistry with one another, here are seven tips on how to have a strong relationship.
Physical contact:
Intimacy plays an important role in a relationship.
Putting your guard down and becoming more vulnerable with each other by either holding hands, hugging, or cuddling,
shows the other person that you have a great interest with them.
Open communication:
Communication is key in a relationship.
You want to be comfortable with your partner and be able to share your thoughts on any type of subject.
You also want to have that mutual agreeance, that you are able to handle any
situations that come your way, and be able to talk them out.
Becoming a friend with the person you are interested before dating them can be a bonus.
Because then you know that they can be your best friend, and you can be comfortable around them.
You have the same sense of humor:
It's important to laugh together, especially when times are tough, and you're able to break the tension somehow.
When you both laugh together at the same thing, it creates a bond between one another,
and you're able to accept each other for who you are.
Emotional bonding:
Having an emotional bond between one another is a good way
to build a connection and be able to trust, and care for each other.
When you ask your partner how their day is, or if they are feeling okay that day,
it lets the other person know that you care, and are taking an interest in what they have to say,
which brings you closer together.
Making up after arguments:
It's important to make amends after an argument, no matter how small or big.
Being stubborn and fighting with one another is what causes you to become distant,
which could lead to a breakup.
Talking to your partner about the fight, and how you two can resolve it, is
a great communication form, and will only bring the two of you closer than ever.
Do not take your partner for granted:
Letting your partner know how special they are, and how much they mean to you,
can keep the relationship strong.
Being there for them is a great way to show that you care.
If a person is constantly letting their partner pay for everything, and pushing away what they have to say,
it's a sign that they're taking that person for granted.
Do you see a future with your partner?
Maintaining the relationship and faith in one another, even in hard situations, is a big deal.
Are you able to always count on your partner?
Planning your future together can be a joyous occasion, in which the two of you will forever share the bond that you have.
If the two of you really care about one another and see a future, do not let them go.
A relationship can be difficult at times, but we hope that those 7 tips can help you.
Don't forget to comment, like this video, and subscribe to our Channel.